let us revamp your film radar with a
comprehensive list of all the
underappreciated movies you have missed
in 2019 and are bound to rave about to
everyone you know as soon as you finally
see them acclaimed director Steven
Soderbergh is three for three of late
and the making movies that go under
appreciated by most people game he
delivered the grossly underrated heist
comedy lucky Logan in 2017 then dished
up his psychological horror flick unsane
in 2018 and now in 2019 Soderbergh has
kept up the street with high flying bird
a subversion of the sports movie genre
that ceaselessly stylish and
respectively risky high-flying for
details the plan sports agent ray Burke
carries out after he stumbles upon a
loophole during a professional
basketball league lockdown shot entirely
on an iphone pipeline Byrd has the kind
of sleek aesthetic and structure that
will grab you by the wrist and send you
down the rabbit hole the love child of
Moneyball and Jerry Maguire bird hit
Netflix's enormous content catalog in
early february around the same time as
some of the streamers more highly
publicized projects having too many
options to choose from is likely why
viewers missed out on the film the good
news is that the fix that this is as
simple as booting it up on Netflix one
of the greatest superhero films of 2019
was one the vast majority of moviegoers
completely missed out on fast color
directed and co-written by Miss Stevens
filmmaker Julia Hart stars the
Cloverfield paradox actress Gugu and
Bottari as Ruth whose seizures caused
massive earthquakes and oranges the new
black alumni rain Tucson tazbo Bruce
mother who has the ability to
disintegrate and reassemble objects with
her mind and to see the colors vivid
flashes of light after you put back
together whatever it is he took apart
everyone sees his object you see the
colors critics agree that fast color is
a movie in a league of its own the movie
critics Sean P means said of the
underappreciated pic in a movie world
overrun with superheroes director Julia
Hart's independent gem fast color
delivers something even more fascinating
characters for whom special powers are
both a curse and a valuable tool in a
cinema landscape littered with space
movies highlight takes a giant leap
ahead of the others in a genre Robert
Pattinson leads the film as Monty a man
who was on death row for killing his
friend
when he was a child Monty his fellow
inmates and their criminal supervisor
dr. dibbs are carrying out a dangerous
mission in space hurtling toward a black
hole for reasons not initially
explicitly known the journey doesn't end
well and the path that the prisoners
walk along is just as devastating my
life isn't a film for everyone there's a
big divide between the critical rating
and audience score on Rotten Tomatoes
but it's perfect for those wanting to
experience something completely new as
the New Republic's Josephine Livingston
wrote my life will send you back into
the world with a totally new idea of
what black holes symbolize it is an
elliptical film yes because it will
answer only the questions that you do
not think to ask director Zhong Jima
redeemed himself for the truly terrible
2017 film the great wall with shadow the
Chinese epic that critics say you have
to see to believe there's so much more
to shadow than meets the eye
like court intrigue hopeless romance
fight sequences that captivates and
weapons that would make comic book
villains drool with envy
but it's the exploration of yin and yang
that makes the film unforgettable movie
pre comm said of it shadow is a
masterful spectacle of human frailty and
intellectual dishonesty that only grows
in resonance as it goes along exalted by
Rolling Stone as quotes one of the best
movies of 2019 by a long shot the last
black man in San Francisco may just be
the top film of the year
it's a rousing soul-stirring haunting
ever from Joe Talbot who makes his
directorial debut with a film that
explores identity truth and belonging in
a city where a pair of best friends no
longer feel there's any space for them
the film which also stars powerhouse
talent Danny Glover Mike Epps
Tichina Arnold and Rob Morgan left
critics moved when a 24 released it in a
limited launch on June 7th beautifully
constructed the last black man in San
Francisco bursts with emotion grapples
with life truths that will resonate with
audiences of all sorts and has the
makings of an unforgettable classic step
aside jaws the best new disaster film
slash creature feature on the block is
crawl set in Florida during a category 5
hurricane crawl follows aspiring college
swimmer Haley as she and her father fend
off a horde of alligators who are out
for blood as time runs out to flee from
Florida the threat of drowning and/or
being eaten alive by the hungry Gators
grows with
passing minute crawl actually scored a
wide release through Paramount Pictures
but that didn't help the film rope in a
huge audience it went mostly unnoticed
at the box office raking in only 55
million dollars worldwide it did however
kick up a ton of talk among critics who
had praised it as quote a lean and mean
thriller well a matte week said of the
film who knew this ridiculous premise
could be so beautifully crafted
immaculately paced and genuinely
shocking a gripping mystery drama from
director julius onah loose picks up ten
years after the adoption of loose Edgar
a bright boy born in war-torn Eritrea
who has become a respected debater in
his high school at all-star athletes and
a beloved member of his Arlington
Virginia community Lucis dazzling
reputation takes an unexpected hit after
he submits an essay that causes
immediate concern one that points to
something far worse than words on a page
the detroit news set of the film this is
a powerful film that shows how far some
will go to protect the reality they
choose to believe it gets into your head
and stays there
loose debuted in theaters in early
August 2019 remaining under the radar
for the entirety of its run with
powerful performances from its cast and
a story that will undoubtedly provoke
discussion this film is one to dissect
and analyze elements of madness writer
Douglas Davison said in a tight 109
minute Sona puts into motion a film
which examines ideas of racial coding
classism parenting academic excellence
nature vs. nurture and more all without
losing an ounce of power or sincerity
bill skarsgård and Micah Monroe play
against type of it's in the Dan Burke
and Robert Olson directed comedy
thriller villains skarsgård who played
penny wise in the hit movies and
burgeoning scream queen monroe portray
mickey and jules a pair of amateur
criminals whose dreamily discussed gas
station robbery goes less like a scene
from Pulp Fiction and more like the
sinking of the Titanic
the couple end up on the run but when
their car breaks down and they seek
refuge at the home of a seemingly normal
couple a horrifying discovery in the
basement turns their home invasion into
a whole other crime entirely come on
maybe there's nothing down here if this
sounds like your cup of tea and you're
now kicking yourself for not having
heard of villains while it was out in
theaters we don't blame you villains a
film that sin
see calls a quote stylish and savage
battle with bad guys is undoubtedly one
of the most fun movies of 2019 it's been
a hot minute since Eddie Murphy put out
a film worth watching
critics put his two most recent films
through the shredder man it seemed that
the actor would never have a hit again
destined to be remembered as a talented
comedian who lost his way or that dude
who boys donkey and the Shrek franchise
that changed with the launch of
Dolomites is my name this biographical
comedy stars Murphy as real-life actor
and singer Rudy ray Moore who gained
fame for his over-the-top character
dolomite in the blaxploitation films
Dolomites the human torpedo and the
dolomite explosion the flick follows
Murphy's more as he discovers the key to
success after a string of failures I
like the film within the film dolomite
is my name is a bonafide smash with
critics but also unlike 1975's dolomite
the 2009 teen movie that tells of its
creation wasn't a box-office hit in its
limited theatrical release it sadly went
unseen by the masses but those who did
catch it had amazing things to say the
Washington Post's and Hornaday wrote
Eddie Murphy is back baby and a
performance so big and so generous that
it virtually busts through the screen
hopefully the Netflix produced biopic
will find more fans on the streaming
service
contrary to what its name suggests Billy
Sinise's mystery suspense film the dead
center didn't end up in the dead center
of moviegoers radars where it did end up
however was on the coveted list of
perfectly rated movies on Rotten
Tomatoes and for good reason
the film stars primer and upstream color
director Shane Carruth as Daniel
Forester a psychiatrist who takes on a
catatonic patient who's unable to recall
how he landed in the hospital at all as
dr. Forrester attempts to connect with
him people all across the ward start
dropping dead and dr. Forrester soon
realizes that he may have unwittingly
unleashed something far more chilling
than even the worst of his personal
demons
Luke white Thompson at Nerdist gave the
dead center a near-perfect score writing
in his review writer director Bill
Sinise proves himself a masterful new
voice in terror specifically the body
horror kind previously dominated by
David Cronenberg you may come out of the
dead center rooting for a sequel I'm
just rooting for whatever Sinise's next
movie is
even especially if it keeps me awake at
night prays nearly universally by
critics for Elizabeth losses lead
performance her smell follows has been
rock superstar Becky something once part
of the 90s female grunge band something
she who now finds herself spiraling in
the wake of her former success written
and directed by Alex Ross Perry her
smell is an unflinching League deep
glamorized look at rock-and-roll stardom
and everything that comes with it as
Becky's Fame and success is consistently
undermined by her own acts of
self-sabotage no you're a mess the film
challenges audiences who are used to
seeing gritty rock biopics of both
real-life and fictional stars play out
in a certain way the typical tropes of
addiction and recovery frenzied highs
and dismal lows and the often tragic
tension between public persona and
personal vulnerability are all there but
not in the ways we necessarily expect to
see them
despite its positive reception from
critics you won't be alone if you missed
her smell during its limited theatrical
run he quotes thrilling funny and
heartbreaking film failed to sell enough
tickets to even make up its modest
budget and much like Becky yourself is
in danger of winding up obscure and
forgotten
despite its artistic greatness in an
increasingly cynical cinematic landscape
it feels almost subversive that a movie
is quiet gentle and kind hearted as the
peanut butter Falcon exists at all
starring Shia LaBeouf a newcomer Zac
gots Asian the peanut butter Falcon
tells the story of an unlikely
friendship forged between a young man
with Down syndrome who dreams have
become at a professional wrestler and
the down-on-his-luck fisherman who
agrees to accompany him on his journey
written and directed by Tyler Nilsson
and Michael Schwartz the peanut butter
Falcon was conceived specifically for
God's Asian who wanted to be an actor
but knew we'd have a hard time getting
cast in Hollywood drawing from many of
his own experiences and ambitions the
Huckleberry Finn inspired narrative
places in front and center and God's
Asian shines as the leading man it
didn't attract large crowds during its
theatrical release but for those who did
manage to catch it on the big screen
both audiences and critics agree that
the peanut butter Falcon was worth the
trip to the theater speaking to slash
film about God's Asian short said he's a
born entertainer we just sat down and
all wrote out a script built a dance
floor and Zack just went out danced
described by writer and director Taika
Waititi as a quote anti-hate satire Jojo
rabbit takes a bold swing for the fences
of good taste and its depiction of a
young Nazi boy named Jojo living through
the waning days of World War two with
his imaginary friend Adolf Hitler ytt
who is himself Jewish plays the
imaginary Hitler with a hefty dose of
irreverence mocking the infamous
dictator and imbuing him of the sense of
half-witted goofiness while never shine
away from the catastrophic effects of
his horrifying beliefs and policies
people used to say a lot of nasty things
about me oh this guy's a lunatic look at
that psycho he's gonna get us all killed
this is the tricky tonal tight rope Jojo
rabbit walks throughout its runtime
attempting the perfectly balanced it's
silly comedy with the gravity of its
subject matter it shouldn't work
reservations about the film's tone
divided critics and perhaps contributed
to keeping the film's box office take
surprisingly modest despite its a-list
cast but audiences seem to agree that
filtering its discordant narrative
through the innocent if deeply misguided
eyes of a child helps Jojo find an
enjoyable rhythm that despite its
wackiness communicates a timely and
earnest message about the dangers of
hate and the power of compassion based
on the 1999 crime novel by Jonathan
Lethem
motherless Brooklyn follows Lionel s
Rock a private investigator with
Tourette's syndrome as he attempts to
solve the killing of his mentor Frank in
1950s New York but digging for the truth
winds up unearthing some secrets that
powerful people would rather keep buried
placing Lionel in the crosshairs of some
of New York's most dangerous players
motherless Brooklyn has long been a
passion project for Edward Norton who
also wrote directed and produced the
film it boasts an impressive cast that
also includes Willem Dafoe Alec Baldwin
Bobby Cannavale II Jerry Jones and
Michael Kenneth Williams
although the critical reception was
somewhat mixed which could have
contributed to the film's disappointing
box-office performance reviews praised
the film strong performances atmospheric
setting and smart writing rights critic
Alexandre Halloran Nicholas motherless
Brooklyn is a love letter to the
long-held focus across film noir on
masculinity in crisis but through Letham
source material and Norton's deep
engagement with it something genuinely
fresh explodes out of seemingly familiar
material on paper honey boy seems like
the type of
that shouldn't work at all the type of
self-indulgent and overly personal fair
that is much more therapeutic for the
filmmaker than it is entertaining for an
audience and yet somehow the Shia
LeBeouf pend film in which he also stars
as his own father manages to defy
expectations delivering a deeply
personal and introspective movie that
also works as a nuanced examination of a
dysfunctional father-son relationship
and a thoughtful commentary on child
actors in Hollywood in a loose
recounting of LaBeouf's own childhood
honey boy mostly follows 12-year old
television star otis who lives his life
between comedy sets and a seedy motel
room which he shares with his father
james a former rodeo clown who now makes
his living as ODIs 'as chaperone as the
adult otis reflects from rehab the
setting in which LaBeouf also wrote
screenplay it can't completely write his
father off much as he may want to and
still finds himself yearning for some
sense of connection both critics and
audiences heaped praise upon honey boy
hailing the Buffs and co-star Noah Jukes
performances and marveling at the depth
and honesty of LaBeouf's writing
fortunately for the majority of people
who missed honey boy in theaters the
bill will begin streaming on Amazon
Prime in February 2020 and riper had an
impressive year in 2019 dominating the
holiday box office with the rise of
Skywalker and co-starring in marriage
story which are in six Golden Globe
nominations including a Best Actor nod
for driver however that same year driver
also starred in a couple other films
that flew under most people's radars
including the well reviewed political
drama the report which opened in limited
release in November 2009 teen the report
follows real-life US Senate investigator
Daniel Jones who led an investigation
into the CIA's use of torture following
the terrorist attacks of September 11th
2001 co-starring alongside driver in the
reports are Annette Bening as Senator
Dianne Feinstein and Jon Hamm as White
House chief of staff Denis McDonough
along with a host of other recognizable
faces most reviewers singled out
driver's performance as exceptional
while many praised the film for its
straightforward and relentless depiction
of true events reviewer James Kendrick
wrote the reports is a particularly
timely reminder about the importance of
the
system of intergovernmental checks and
balances within a constitutional
democracy during a time when that system
seems more endangered than ever the
report wasn't in theaters for long but
unfortunately for anyone who missed it
it's now streaming on Amazon Prime in
2021 Robert Pattinson will make his
hopefully triumphant return to major
franchise fare when he'll star as Bruce
Wayne in the Batman until then he's
keeping plenty busy with smaller
artistically ambitious films that
challenge both actors and audiences
alike such as the black and white
psychological horror film the lighthouse
starring opposite Willem Dafoe the
lighthouse follows a pair of lighthouse
keepers who gradually lose their grip on
sanity after a storm traps them on the
remote island directed by the witch
filmmaker Robert Edgar's who also
co-wrote the screenplay with his brother
Max the lighthouse is a surreal and
disturbing descent into madness with
standout performances from both
Pattinson and Dafoe it may be a little
too bizarre for the casual film fan one
critic called it a quote visceral
assault on the senses with others
warning that it is quote rough going and
the opposite of a crowd-pleaser but
these appear to be features not bugs
playing into the overall effectiveness
of the film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]